It's weird. Right?
Because I feel like manga readers just exist in their own bubbles. Right.
Cause when we talk about the anime community,
most people refer to it as like the animated Monga community. It's it's we, we,
we kind of, we're kind of,
we're kind of assume that we're just so synonymous with each other. Right.
But then there are times when I just kind of realized that I have no idea what's
going on in the Mongo world sometimes. Like there's this recent, uh,
there's this airing anime right now called a Hottie Mia. That, uh, so good.
Yeah, exactly. It's exactly. May or may. It may,
Lynn's just like fam the monger, his favorite Mongo
[inaudible] is getting adapted.
There was like so many manga readers that they come out, they just come out,
just come out and say, Oh my God, this is my favorite Monga. I love this Mongo.
And here I am thinking where where's this rock?
What is this wrong? This is the thing, right.
I say six out of 10, but I'm sure they're like me. They're like,
I forget about it. But when the Mo the anime is announced.
Yo, yo, that's my favorite. I love that one. I read that ages ago.
I loved that.
The thing is I had never heard of Hadi Mia before the anime got adopted this
winter season. Right. And I'm just like, it must be a pretty, like,
it must have like a cult following or something. So search it up. And.
Oh, it has a call following. It is.
The 13th, most popular Mongo of all time on Miami list.
And I'm just like, how will I have, how have I never heard this name before?
Or how's no one discussed this in my presence before reading bad.
Well, that's the thing.
What I find so interesting about the Monga wold is that even if it's like
universally praised and credited as being this most amazing piece of work right
in the Mongo wall,
it's just really surprising how few people in the enemy community actually know
about it. Like I guaran T not many people know about like me Puente food,
even though I think it's like the second or third highest rated Mongo on Val,
I feel like, I feel like, I dunno some like sane in Monga. You,
you have like the sane in big four. I think you have like, Binland saga.
Always the big numbers. It is because it's not quite the meeting.
[inaudible] to the top. That, that, that describes things pretty well.
Nevermind.
We should rename it. [inaudible]
It might be, it might be three. I can't remember. Cause it's it's all.
Which ones are you referring to? The crowd that always talk about Binland saga.
It's either villain saga, berserk, or a Camry.
Vagabond. Vagabond. Yeah. I think there's one more.
That is in that genre that everyone keeps savy golden. Calmly. No,
that's not going Camry, but maybe it's just a big three. Maybe,
maybe I'm just imagining things. But like,
I feel like a lot of sane in Monga gets talked about as like these masterpieces,
you know what I mean? But some like slice of life, romance, Monga,
like Hardy Mia that is apparently very popular,
just don't get talked about in the same sphere.
And I would argue that even the big, the big three scene,
and I guess we've coined it now, like Bailey had told us about light.
It upsets me how few people know about like valuable. Really? Yeah.
I feel like a lot of people know.
About. Yeah. That's awesome.
I know it is a title that exists. I know. Absolutely nothing.
Think about it. So vagabond essentially is a it's a samurai Mongo. Yeah,
but I would, but it's done by, uh, the author who did slammed.
On. Oh, okay. That sounds cool. So you.
Know where somehow not only my has to make one of the greatest sports market
ever made, but also one of the greatest salmon.
Yeah. It's amazing. Okay. How many chapters is it? It's still going.
It's still ongoing, but it's on hiatus.
I dunno what it is about this, you know, the,
the brutal scene in Mongo where they get up to like 200 or 300 chapters in the
officious, like I'm ahead of that.
Yeah. I'll take a break. I think I, the Monga I've read,
it feels like they build up like a really cool world. And again, they just like,
it either gets too big and they're just like, right, right. To reign this in.
Or like, it just gets way too big. And it ends with like so many things. Not.
I explored because going back to Hunter Hunter,
like it got up to a point where I'm just like, this is a,
this is a comfortable place to end it. You know what I mean?
It's a comfortable place to like, yeah, no, it definitely.
Could have ended it. And then she introduces the dark continent,
which without spoiling the exact details of it is so you have,
you have the ones that we're going to see the end of it. You have this,
you have this world, that's a gushy buildup in Hunter Hunter. Right.
And it was like, how, how long was like the it, whatever,
the 148 episodes, 148 episodes. Right.
And it ended to a point where you explored everything you needed to explore
about the world. Right. And he went on hiatus and everyone was just like, Oh,
you know, Hunter, Hunter must be coming to an end. Right.
And then he comes back and he's just like, JK, by the way,
this is just one fifth of the way.
Well, that's, I hate it when they do that, man, like, don't,
don't come here and pull it out of your.
It's like a like iPhone presentation. It's like, but wait, okay.
There's more, it's like, wait, but no salt.
It shouldn't be as cool as the idea is of like expanding the world.
It's honestly one of the things that makes me roll my eyes, emotion.
I've been reading Monga lately, but there's another constant or planet.
And I'm like, Oh, for,
there is not going to be another planet that has gotta be satisfied.
Yeah. That's, that's exactly how I felt when like, uh.
You know, in like dragon ball, when they started expanding on like,
[inaudible] like, bro.
Like I don't like blowing up planets and like taking over the universe was hard
enough. And now it's like, well, uh, you know,
there's like seven more universes out there that we can explore.
Nothing gets my job,
like softer than hearing multi-verse or like expanding the universe out of
like.
One thing I hate the most is how, like,
I don't mind them like introducing that kind of thing. If they actually.
Followed through with it, they'll just, and like a chapter, they'll be like, Oh,
by the way, there's other worlds. No, there wasn't. There was never,
you never made this mango with other worlds in mind, you liar,
you're adding this now. Cause like, okay,
sorry to bring it up again for like the ninth tie.
But like w what I was reading Claymore, they just casually mentioned that like,
there's two worlds having a wall and then it's like never brought up again.
And then they just itch. It ends.
And we never hit anything about the other world.
That's apparently having a war and it's like, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa.
So everyone gets to go low and happy. But the whole,
why this world exist is because there was a war and this is like a testing.
It's really. Like, I don't, I don't like it when they do this,
especially when the Monga is like, you know,
it's been going on for a long time and it already feels like it's stretching
thin. And then they'll like another world, baby. It's like, no, no, no, no, no.
Because I think you said if they build it up fine, but when they just drop it,
I hate it.
You sometimes see these plot points in Monga. It's just like dropped.
And for some reason you just never, ever hear about it. Again,
like aside from other worlds,
the biggest example I can think of is the Gantz Monga. Oh my God.
Well, I love that one, but I was so dumb. Yeah.
I just like,
remember when there were vampires in it and that was a big plot points.
And then they just disappeared. Just never heard about it again.
There's a lot of stuff in jail. So if you haven't read Gans, I guess you could,
uh, it's very long. It's red. The artwork is amazing. We spoke about it before,
but yeah, randomly, halfway through,
they introduced vampires into a world that never had vampires.
And then they just never come up again. Not gonna lie.
Like I barely remember any of it because I think at that point I kind of just
like erased it from my mind. I was like, this is so dumb.
I don't even want to like potato. It's a memory.
I just kind of, I always offhand remember edge, you know,
sometimes you just get flat.
I wake up at night sweating. Yeah. You wake up, there was grandpa.
You wake up and you're just like, whatever happened to those vampires,
what did they disappear? They were built up.
That's like the big villains or something. And then they just,
they just went nowhere with it.